here in the valley a new mural is going
up to honor the 21 lives lost in the
uvalde school shooting jeremy j ford was
there as the painting started and joins
us live in the newsroom with more on the
project jeremy that's right community
members came together today to paint 21
hearts on a large wall in the west
valley the mural faces the busy street
near charleston and rainbow
now volunteers work together to honor
the memory of those lost to gun violence
the mural a tribute to the uvalde texas
school shooting victims was created by
local artist janelle rail she says she
wants to make a difference and help
people heal during these hard times
people going to school people going to
the grocery store people going to a
music concert should have
the right to feel safe
and
that
they can enjoy the things that we enjoy
without fear of
of being shot or being hurt
by some unknown person that has no
relation to them
other than trying to cause harm to
others
now more than 50 people showed up to
help paint the wall located on the
corner of antelope and peggy
and the painting is scheduled to be
finished by the end of next week in the
newsroom jeremy j ford live local now